I know that you've been you know trained
as a fighter and I just was thinking to
myself it's I know I'm long in the tooth
but there are times in my life where I
think maybe now I could I could I could
pick it up maybe I could pick it up now
I'm not even kidding because it's such a
great workout
you analyze me analyze me as a fighter
I'm I've got the height and the reach
that reach that you got the you got
those long arms right I would want
nothing to do with you man I like I like
it but wait like seeing you in the gym
if you just walked in I would look at
the length is a serious serious thing
I am but you can you can John punch
someone in the face John burntall is
telling me that I have it why do you
have to punch someone in the face why
can't he just punch a bag or hit a hand
pack and start training there are no
there are some people I really want to
hear we'll get there that's always one
of them's in this room
yeah I'd love to see the two of you my
problem is I think it would be could I
take a punch you know I think you could
man I think you could it I think it's a
lot I got my nose smashed in uh I got
jumped by some by a bunch of people uh
when I was a was a a graduated high
school and it was before I started
college and I wandered into sort of a
dicey neighborhood in Boston and I
realized I was in a neighborhood I was
supposed to be in and I was wearing a
t-shirt that had the Irish flag on it
which I'm not kidding that had been a
gift from my uncle who'd been to Ireland
and had the Irish flag on I wasn't
thinking about it but apparently I was
in an Italian neighborhood and uh so um
I got my nose smashed in uh by uh some
fellows who didn't like who didn't like
the cut of my jib that's how I described
him to the police who hit you Mr Butt
there were these fellows they didn't
like the kind of but um but after that I
thought like man you know and the police
were asking me like what would you do
and you realize you're about to get hit
like what stance did you go into and I
went stance
because I'm told I had been a little bit
of a wise guy too yeah yeah yeah yeah
well you know what's crazy about that is
you actually told me that the first time
that's how I did your show you said
because we talked about the size of my
deformed just a disgusting excuse for a
nose and how many times it had been
broken and then you said to me and then
and then in the the pause in the
commercial break I leaned over to and
I've always been so intrigued about what
the hell people actually talk about in
those moments because besides with you
it's always been a super super awkward
conversation I've had that great
conversation but that one I I went over
to and I said hey man those guys that
hit you do think they now know that they
hit you and you looked at me like I was
the like and you were like dude it was
before it was like before I was in
college I just said that and I and then
the next time I saw you I tried to bring
it up with you but I think I kind of
failed again man and it failed no no I
think I just was thinking like no those
guys have no idea but you don't think
that they beat up Connor Brian and if
they did they'd be like good if
kind of red-headed guy
they beat so many people up that they
don't remember they might I don't know
that's the rub if they're hitting them
just for the FL but you know there could
have been other reasons that they hit
you which could have been you know your
size your you know otherwise they asked
for money and I said no and they said
why not and I said I don't feel like it
and the time between me putting the
period on don't feel like fatigue don't
feel like it I didn't even see it coming
it was like bang bang and then the
anti-italian word that you threw at him
right before you did that I swear to God
I did not do that then I would have had
it coming but uh but um the funny part
of the story to me is that my mom got
called and she was at work and the
person who called her from like the
emergency room because I just walked to
an emergency room and just blood
everywhere and I and the person who
called her said uh we have your son here
Conan he was attacked by a mob and she
said attack by a mob and my mom went
yeah okay I'm coming
didn't even question knew that like yeah
that wise guy I'm sure I'm up she didn't
question it at all she's like yep I'm on
my way were you by yourself I was with a
friend of mine who I later who I
um didn't see for many many many many
many years and then a couple of years
ago my friend John and I reconnected and
one of the first things we talked about
was I said you were there that day I was
like oh yeah I remember you know you
were you're being a little bit of a wise
guy
you skinny tall you in an Irish Flag
t-shirt walking through what I imagine
is like the Robert De Niro version of
God yeah it was 1970 yeah it was 1917.
he just wanted to wet his b
itch
that's amazing
but anyway uh I think that's when I
realized like no I I it is a great form
of exercise and I've always
um I grew up uh it's one of six a couple
of brothers and constant like fake
fighting but also real fighting
wrestling and so that has been my
relationship with a lot of other males
in my life has been a man and my son
um even when he was a little kid when I
see him I would chase him and Tackle him
and we were rough house I don't do it
now because over covid he uh grew to be
exactly my height he's 6'4 and he's
really [ __ ] strong and so now when I
quote have a fun wrestle with my son
suddenly my head is going through a wall
and I'm like okay maybe we're gonna
just tell me where to you know you're
encouraging me you're saying I could go
I could work on a speed bag there is
literally a gym right down Steve Petra
Molly's gym is right down the street
he's the best in the world you can start
training there you you would you would
never regret it and you would whoop the
snot out of your son when you're done
you know what this is the best podcast
episode we've ever done we're gonna
promote you should not be empowered any
more than you are I know
years ago when I hosted Saturday Night
Live I had a night there was I told them
the writers beforehand there's one
sketch I want to do I want to play an
Irish boxer
um I think you can look at it it was
being I think it was in the year 2000
but I I play a boxer who boxes this
style but I'm going against a real boxer
and it's just me getting pummeled you
know but I'm I'm doing this and bouncing
up into I've always thought what would
it be like if a guy tried to do that try
to do that today against like Floyd
Mayweather yeah come here Floyd I'll
give you a pasting
come and step in Floyd I'll show you
I'll give you some creamed corn you know
that kind of [ __ ] I love it man uh
so corn yeah that's my favorite insult
I'll give you some creamed corn okay
you're going to get so bad
Mrs O'Brien your son's been inside I
know by a mob the creamed corn thing
yeah it sounds like John didn't do a
damn thing huh yeah really John was
smart it happened it was it happened
fast so there wasn't much and not on
John at all because this was not a long
fight yeah yeah this was like this was
not a fight this was like this was not a
fight at all this was I was a a uh a
giant uh Hummel figurine and I think
there was one or two punches and I
shattered and then John had a dustpan
got it picked up the pieces and took me
to the emergency room so uh yeah John
John was very nice he took good care of
me after I had quickly inflicted all the
damage on myself listen if you're one of
these Italian uh youths that remember
you and Conan O'Brien back then if you
want to come on the real ones
yes by the way yeah that's right I'm
gonna you're happy and Johnson's even
gonna call me and say they cracked him
down yeah I'm gonna just hear like we
got someone on today he uh he took some
wrong turns back in the day in Boston he
punched out Conan O'Brien but you know
what he's a guy who made his mistakes
he's owned and you're not even going to
give me a heads up right anyway uh just
to show our appreciation if you come to
the show we bought you a Dodge Charger
it's out front
[Laughter]
[Laughter]